good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
today's Tuesday October 10th and I have
a very special guest co-host filling in
for Jackie today it is the one the only
it's right joey camasta can you explain
why your instrument mr. P it's very
confusing
it's a baby name my parents gave me when
I was a child that's cute so what does
that to do with being at their sponsor
on Instagram nothing it's just like kind
of like I don't want to put my real
names that's boring so I did like Mr P I
thought use of it
you're like girls our job yep that's my
that's my girl nut job name but what is
mr. Peavey it's like baby it's howling
baby truck when I was like hey my father
would be like Oh mr. P feeling dirty oh
is that like an Italian thing it's like
yeah battalion gibberish and my sister's
name is Lauren her name's Lali P so it's
like that's cute
there's no really rhyme or reason to it
but I think it was marketable so is your
sister older or younger I have to I have
older sister Dana and a younger sister
Laura and I'm in the middle and how do
they feel about you I'm sure they just
have to deal with it I mean I get along
with both of them ya know they're very
good so in case you don't know Joey Joey
is so many things influencer podcaster
hair makeup artist as well correct
so you co-host the it's happening it's
all happening it's happening it's
happening podcast is Snooki yes we're
also Snooki's glam glam and you were at
Mr P 79 at Mr P 79 on Instagram on
Instagram and now joey camasta at on
twitter and youtube I want to start
youtubing I told you you should I know
so I bought all this equipment so now I
go full studio in my house but I don't
know how to use anything so I'm just
learning slowly but yeah you know watch
some YouTube videos on how to do yeah
I'll see you tube how to make a youtube
video um also am I suppose to be looking
at camera it's a little bit about well
cuz you're at home I'm talking to people
at home so if you're talking to me look
at me but if you want to give out you
know public service announcement or just
like ah it'd be thirsty like for
followers look that way that's why
that's why I always like okay we've done
a podcast episode before your podcast
and I got a lot of feedback and people
were like oh my god you talk so fast I
couldn't understand a single thing now I
talk really fast but literally one of
five people who can keep up with me and
talk just as fast exactly we get very
excited and we don't have to let you
know we're like yeah and we like talk
over each other your speed reading you
ever see those speed reading people know
like speed read and they're like
to people and they're like but that's
fake yeah I don't know how to read them
but we just get very overexcited and we
just know how to mm-hmm and we're very
similar and how did we meet
well everyone you know what I love about
the toasters they're always telling me
like who I'd be to meet and most of the
time they're right yes so everyone's
like you gotta meet you same with her
they said you know everyone saying like
you have to have her in the podcast you
have to tell her on the podcast you have
to meet I never knew who she was so I
like Google I was like a little shy a
little something here than me I think I
guess she is funny and I'm like Chanel
and then it was love at first sight true
dad also wait I had a really good
question for you [ __ ] what are you doing
I threw my first it's my last day of
this tray of him his Alliance Oh
are you pleased with Invisalign I was
thinking about doing a smile direct Club
okay yes I'm with them okay and oh do
you like it I love it it's my last tray
before I get my retainers smile oh they
look nice q but before picture not on me
no not on you no I want before a picture
of my double chin tell me what I did
what I've been I've been CoolSculpting I
can't feel my entire [ __ ] face I want
the other day I get double session on
this turkey gobble here if you punch me
here I can't dessert
no it's just completely not does the
cool spot hurt no it does not hurt is it
expensive I don't know could you pay you
get for free yeah okay well can I mean
to be waffles can I give a shot is
luminous about face it luminous in New
Providence New Jersey dr. Richard Maggie
on the team there are fabulous and I um
I love it I didn't dude you look good
thank you I got done my thighs and my
neck I would do my sides cuz now my neck
is perfect yeah I said you know take a
look take me King everything I got yeah
I'm so jealous that you got two for free
I had to pay for my neck but it was the
best money ever but you went to like a
fancy Upper East Side don t Ramona
singers doctor like what did I expect
oh my god no I know she looks great I
can't even no I need the cami tell us
anything there before actually look at
some pictures do you have it in a jar at
home no but I did ask her to look at it
afterwards and it looked like Smuckers
jelly but not strawberry wasn't that red
it was like pink it was like apricot jam
don't believe she's apricot or apricot
apricot apricot me too I don't know why
I just said apricot that was weird so we
obviously have a wide range of stories
that we're gonna deliver and we also
we're gonna later in the show how do you
owe me with questions about so many
things but I have a lot of Jersey Shore
drama that I need some clarification on
and I feel like you're the perfect
person I'll talk about it I have a dog
who's like you
are there and you experience it but you
don't sign anything because like you're
not like contracted to be there so you
can say whatever you want and I'm really
excited about that and if you have any
questions for Joey comment them on
YouTube I'll check YouTube in a little
bit but before that wait has these I
just like these little phone things are
you watching questions on your phone
well so usually I do when it's very
distracting but today because jack is
not here I have to do the stories oh man
is that a butt on your Instagram yeah
you follow an Instagram account called
the Harry hunk and they have a big
Coulee on there by this we call it but
okay you need help finding the Instagram
the YouTube yeah okay cuz I know you're
like sorry dude the YouTube app on here
yes I do
oh you're such a youtuber I know and I
also the YouTube capture app so you can
like make videos on there and like post
it right away oh I didn't even know that
was a real it's oh my god sorry about
the first okay I just have to for a
second your youtube search history joey
camasta paw patrol paw Patrol I have
kids in my life yes excuse me you are
not subscribe to the morning toast
subscribe oh no I didn't know that I put
it on faceplace what's Facebook Facebook
that's okay so here is the feed for you
and here all your well that's why I look
yeah oh my god you guys don't tell me to
sit up and then you could be the
comments if you put it on your phone
Stan but it can be quite distracting as
I can as you can see yeah I could see
how [ __ ] fat I am
I'm so sorry for anyone home with him
had breakfast yeah well you want to know
what a lot of people listen to this as a
podcast so everything like relieving
really it's a relief for me okay so I'm
gonna be using my face from now on so if
I sit to the side no yeah you have to
learn it took me almost six months to
figure out how to sit on this show well
now yes I have I don't move oh it's much
better this way okay are you sure yeah
okay well you wanted to you in a request
that you wanted to say so without
further ado Joey's gonna deliver this
and now these are the fast five stories
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning I may be
a little sad that it went um thank you
that was so great can you practice that
in the mirror I practice it every day
and I also been cinch on the toast has
been on my my my brain you have 24 hours
to do it
snitch on the joes
said John that you've a good voice I
feel like you might I could know do you
though I mean it's okay I mean I I try
to Sid Whitney Houston when we do
karaoke carioca it never works I had
more of a Bon Jovi okay delivers some
buns over your illness please um give
the people what they want songs to do
what's a Bon Jovi song whoa wow that's
um
I thought you would buck maybe have
weirdly have a good voice you know well
sometimes I don't really know I can't be
put on the spot oh that's fair that's
fair okay well let's let's dive right in
because I feel like a lot of news
happened yesterday some days go by and
I'm like oh nothing happened today but
then it's everything happened yesterday
yes and the first is a little confusing
because news broke and then it was like
pulled back so Dakota Johnson's rep
denies that's the girl from the Fifty
Shades from the porno the denies that
she's pregnant with Chris Martin's child
after a report surfaces the gup-x coupe
where the Paltrow's ex-husband Chris
Martin has been dating for a year they
just celebrated our one-year anniversary
Dakota Johnson the girl from the porno
and yesterday TMZ had this whole article
about how they're pregnant and they had
all these pictures I really both from
Great Britain
neither of that Oh actually maybe Chris
Martin okay she's not she is the
daughter of two people that are old and
famous and I don't know their names
that's irrelevant
Oh Don Johnson cuz Takota John Oh and
Melanie Griffith Griffin Griffith
really yeah those are her parents that's
why she got the role of Fifty Shades
even though she was like holy
unqualified for and it was like the role
that everyone wanted I was so hot yeah
and the idea originally cast it was way
hotter yeah but then he backed out
didn't perform Henry yes he got a
Superman that's just such a better role
Jimmy Jordans fine he's like a little
skinny mm-hmm we like him big obviously
hmm okay so yesterday TMZ reported that
they were pregnant and they had all
these pictures of baby shower being
thrown at their house it was pink and
blue balloons
celebrities showed up like and they had
these amazing photos
was it a gender-reveal party right and
then it they said it was a boy like did
all the info
hmm and now they're saying her rep is
saying it's not true so this is
according to people she's setting the
record straight after rumors of a
pregnancy a rep for the 29 year old
actress says Johnson is not pregnant
after reports that pink and blue
balloons were spotted above the home of
her boyfriend Coldplay frontman Chris
Martin on Sunday
according to rep Johnson was celebrating
birthday with pastel which is October
4th in real life at his house guests
spotted the at the event were her
parents Melanie Griffith and Don Johnson
as well as Julia Roberts and Sean Penn
no they were just there together okay
but this is odd
well what kind of birthday party has
pink and blue balloons no one it was
definitely their gender reveal but then
if they knew it was a boy bars be
revealing maybe it was like they were
veal to other people
Oh God they already knew right right
right thinking blue yeah but her
birthday is October 4th I was literally
five days ago Lily what was I don't
understand why would be pink oh that's
very shady Shaddai yeah I'm sure
probably it's not the Sheep I just want
to tell anyone you have but it's like
now that it's out you're gonna lie about
it yeah then you're like like okay ready
Kylie Jenner's lip fillers right this
here's a perfect example
Mercedes job eat is pregnant is that MJ
from Shahs of Sunset
oh she's been here yes yeah I have you
know very good source her baby with
Tommy they got married MJ is the last
best friend yeah huge boobs yeah
so she was pregnant they it came out
literally a week ago it should people
had the exclusive I knew three weeks ago
cuz she was here no I wouldn't turn my
source oh and I posted it on our
Instagram and our Facebook and our
Twitter and she responded to me no I'm
not
she was like oh my god I feel I felt so
bad I'm like oh my god I liked I just
deleted everything
oh she like personally told you girls
yeah and now a People magazine exclusive
that she is like please I knew it first
and I was right so why would she tell me
she's because she wanted the mind from
people right okay it's exactly what it
was I understand so Jeff Dakota Johnson
has an exclusive with someone else I'm
sure yeah times know yeah she's so bad
she'll announce it on vote yeah it's you
we're pregnant yes and you wanted to do
an announcement with a publication and
you could have your pick of the litter
I'm juggs magazine yeah they never do
something like National Enquirer yeah no
I mean I want to take whoever I can get
but I probably do Nicole always uses Us
Weekly so I probably use less because
they've been really great to Nicole and
and you have a contact yeah the contract
horse Snoopy if you'd like or snicky
yeah
does she like the name story no she
hates it I'm like people always hate the
nickname
I mean she used to cuz that's her brand
and she's got two grams on it but when
people do it sure she's like it's Nicole
right I guess that's a no way she's like
a mom now like yeah her by her call me
by your name that's what that movie was
about right yes exactly about a reality
star the head is now okay so I want to
talk about all that I have a list of
things I want I won't talk to you about
but okay as far as we know Dakota
Johnson says she's not pregnant
I have a feeling in a couple months like
a baby's gonna pop out and then like
everyone forgets about the big lied that
she told her and her rap but Ashley way
she's not married to the guy they just
obeyed their one-year-anniversary and I
don't not like she's five years old and
she's pregnant what is everyone so
dramatic for I know but I have a feeling
he's not the most faithful who shows my
look like an [ __ ] if I guess she's
like her boyfriends out there [ __ ]
other people
yeah what's your favorite curse word um
probably [ __ ] yeah
cuz there's so many different use for it
yeah it can be a noun a verb an
adjective and adverb yeah I mean not an
adverb actually that would be [ __ ] Li
yes I know someone that you oh crap yeah
can be used any Content I can you
explain the background behind that
annoying thing that you say okay no the
other one grah call me that one yes I
can't so I think that's when I came on
your podcast who said it a hundred times
and honestly had no idea we were talking
abut I was like laughing okay quick
choice this is what we came up with this
so me and a call we were at the
Hollywood Roosevelt Hotel we were in
like this like suite and we were in our
backyard little backyard but the
background the fence we were there for
the apprentice I think yes but she
forced herself home day to day three -
mr. kids she so we were in the backyard
at the hotel and Davis big fence and I'm
like on the fence it's like very tall so
like no one can like to see us no caps
but they can hear us we can hear people
walking on the streets next - so we're
wasted and we're sitting like in
bathrobes like bombed out of our minds
drink you like vodka in champagne and
then we hear like people walking by so
really let's pretend we're having sex
so we're like so we do this all the time
like you know we'll start like making
noise like and this is a man I'm
assuming he was homeless because we
heard wrestling around so he goes oh
oh shoot could I call man and we it was
like so loud cuz like it was like
peeking through the fans right we
screamed at the table where I ran inside
like hid under the covers it was a
terrifying you were always doing [ __ ]
like that yeah it was like like naps
where we get so from that bit was like
in our minds for the rest of our lives
Krakow me I like when things like that
have good backstories yeah so now we
have our own tagline could I come in
come ah yeah
yeah okay okay thank you I like your
tattoo yeah what does it say this one
here you've so many explains my latest
attempt to it says love you mommy and
daddy my mom has crossed over my mom has
passed
is that the real handwriting exact
handwriting sighs the last birthday card
she gave me I loved it and I should make
me Isabella and she got the same thing
she copied me it was my idea first and
she got the one from her last birthday
card for my grandmother and we got the
same tattoo same Henry he's very iconic
candidate it's very lovely handwriting
yeah so she was Catholic school and they
used to hit her with a ruler yeah and
tell me about that big ball of fire
around that big heart that is most
Italian tattoo I've ever seen if you
ever listen to the podcast let me tell
you it is a red heart wrapped in my
favorite part
oh sorry of Jesus it's a Sacred Heart of
Jesus so for the Jewish people watching
it's a red heart
yeah with barbed wire around it with a
cross on top with fire ribbon around it
the test camasta and a blue ray of light
order oh god yeah yeah so this is a
Sacred Heart it's my first set show I
got and I just loved this because it was
so gory
yeah it is and my last name was on it
and I don't know I just thought I was
one I like colorful tattoos I also had
this when I joined a gang oh it's a gun
in a rose what was the meaning behind
that there wasn't when I saw I'm this
like hot model guy and was like on his
side like all the way down by this
wasn't an option fingering
given the I got it here instead and I
just I was like you know I was like you
know hanging out in Brooklyn a lot of
course yeah I felt let go toward a
relevé yeah younger vibes yeah okay well
I'm happy for you I'm having a
particular Johnson whatever is in her
belly what's in your belly this morning
you eat breakfast
nothing I've Alex I'm doing intermittent
fasting I'm not eating you till one
o'clock today okay and then what do you
eat at one o'clock I
I'm gonna have to them probably I'm
probably not gonna be bad to take some
chocolate fasting can you eat whatever
yeah but I used the Paleo diet so don't
you like any bread or the last time I
was eating people we were wasted oh no
that's that's the last time yeah podcast
on your podcast me i ate kosher that day
it was the best pizza yeah and then that
night we went to a diner that was a
different night yeah like a week later
yeah we went to a diner and I had I
don't know what I prayed then cuz I was
about like bombed yeah I think I had a
grilled cheese mm-hmm okay high def ELT
if you don't remember it the calories
don't count yeah well I remembered that
okay okay a second story news broke
yesterday about our girl Bethenny
Frankel before we debit okay I like I
like that I like her dry punchlines and
I like her sense of humor I think she is
when she came back from being a talk
show host she thought that she was
[ __ ] Madonna or some like godly
creature and like treated everyone else
like an [ __ ]
Madonna's a godly creature no not
personally I just want to make sure but
Jamie she like thought that she was yet
better than everyone else
you know so but in this moment in the
Carole in the whole thing of it all
where do you stand politically I mean I
think I think she just tells it how it
is now and that's why I'd like about her
now so if you had to pick a side team
Carole a team Metheny probably team
Bethenny okay gonna be TIG yeah I need
to know Carole seems like she's playing
the victim a lot yeah and like she's
just so irrational when everything that
comes out of her mouth is live but like
I literally can't invest anymore time
and talking about it because I literally
I gave I gave this what this is so take
that ten-year-old boy I'm on and off
they get coffee and I think ice that's
her way of saying what's a truck like
why would you want to go there he's hot
like but I actually don't think he's
attractive and I don't think him me oh
my god I also don't think him like
making lettuce wraps is attractive like
if you're gonna be the chef like make me
a burger that's manly steak I don't want
like your special salad you know to me
that's not attractive
yeah she's not really my type and I
really feel like they're perfect for
each other
okay what is your type anyone I can hold
down that won't run away and cheat on me
I don't really have one
yeah I mean we'll do like a dating
segment at the end we'll say maybe out
there there's hot guys at work in this
building
well when TBG comes on the points guy
mm-hmm he tells me he always gets like
hot DMS from toaster gay toasters oh
yeah so why Figgy toasters I'm talking I
want I want to smell like you know some
of us
oh my god totally wait there's so many
perks for like in his own plane that has
like he's in he's in kicked at me what
does he do for work he's the points guy
his company is literally worth like
millions of dollars what is he he just
tells you about to get points so he
started a blog like back in the day and
it was acquired by like a travel company
and he works with all these credit card
companies and he works with all these
airlines he kills it
he's the one that said that you're sad
with us at the VMAs yes okay did he say
anything about me that night like stick
it in his butt
he didn't say that specifically but I
didn't ask you know okay you never know
I'm always trying things attract him I
would date him besides just forgetting
three points ya know I've set him up
with one person so far and they had a
good time but it wasn't like a great
love I love setting people up okay I can
say that because your ish what is it sir
I am a your your I'm an e-stop but the
Jewish knows [ __ ] off I'm gonna [ __ ]
often what does this do oh I hate so
much at any point if you want to serve
justice like you feel like something's
not going right
don't hit the glass though don't hit the
glass exactly I'm good so it's like you
know justice for David Foster everyone
made it seem like he left Yolanda when
she was sick but she was really quietly
quietly a pain in the ass
yeah justice needs to be served for him
like that
okay so Bethenny Frankel has been
spotted kissing a mystery man a mystery
man and obviously People magazine asked
to be Shady in their headline nearly two
months after Dennis shield stuff like if
this is how she wants to grieve [ __ ] off
everyone thinks so judgmental i I just I
defend her to the death almost two to a
fault did you have a phone number no
okay but she just recently follow me on
instagram i'll be damned once that's
yeah i do want to talk about what
happened last night and your home Oh
following your husband so one of the
toasters let me know that re on the
ground a recently followed been on
Instagram and you know we have a decent
amount of celebrities that follow us I
think my claim to fame is that Harry
Styles follows me so Jackson for a while
um let me stopped yeah for a while when
up one of the Trump kids followed me
which one uh Tiffany get it yeah like
not really she's like she's like a be
like the modern the modern-day touch
higher Tara Reid I think doesn't she get
bombs and messy yes so like she
unfollowed me I wasn't that upset I'm
not gonna lie but um I just
like I've had it like some cool brushes
with celebs but this one is the craziest
just because of how many followers she
has she's 130 million and she does yeah
and that's like Ben gets that that 130
ml now what if she stood in tizzy I was
an ass like pens like to hang out
without you though oh my god about a
hundred was that make him and like wear
a camera okay and like I would go to the
spice store and get like an earpiece I'd
hide in a bus with you and just have to
heat up to livestream it to show ya
welcome so the real hospice in New York
star was in Boston over the weekend and
she was spotted getting affectionate
with a mystery man on Sunday she was
photographed holding hands with someone
at a crosswalk he's sporting at a
crosswalk he sported an all-black outfit
with sneakers while she kept a casual in
the cream spider dark grey pants and
high high-heeled sneakers saying a day
later the mother of one was snapped
kissing him again on Monday morning near
Boston College where she grabs for his
face with her left hand as he leaned in
for a smidge Wow okay People magazine is
being very specific well how long were
her and that man dating before he passed
they were on and off for like a while oh
maybe two years and there were rumors
that they were engaged
Oh wallet after like during hey what did
he take honeycomb say did he kill him
suffer is a mistake so I believe it was
an accidental overdose because he and
his assistant had a narcan on hand which
systemically was the same thing great
it's the latter so that's it move and
I've been hearing that it's like
celebrities are just like acquiring it
in their houses you can get narcan at
CVS you can yes I think so
so you've narcan and like it brings you
back to life and they don't even have to
go to the hospital like a lot because
once you go to the - yeah once you go to
the hospital like your medical records
like TMZ can get them yeah
so these celebrities are overdosing
narcan ting and then not getting
treatment like they're not go in the
hospital or anything they found a
loophole
right so Dennis his assistant had narcan
on hand and I believe that she tried to
administer it but it was too late so I
don't know if he it was unclear but it
would all signs point to the it being an
accidental I found the housekeeper found
him the assistant I thought it so be
some of the only things I'm person to
find me in my house it's a domino
delivery person they come looking for me
because there's not a call been made in
the past 24 hours my house what do you
order food from like where's your go to
Oh seamless I just used seamless so I
use all different places are you open to
trying new places yes
driving past a place you order from
frequently and it's like dirty yes and
you like oh that's what I'm getting it
from it's always so good of course yeah
I love marinara pizza on that Prius side
because they have cauliflower Chris yes
well loves it too so good cauliflower
crust pizza and they also have zoodles
so you can get like zoodles instead of
your pasta and any sauces so I'll do
sorry my less is a fresh day with my
sponsor it close you can get zoodles
with bolognese it's like my favorite
thing and it's like basically européenne
lettuce yeah it's like the marinara
shout-out to you guys
hit me up if you want to give me some
free food wait so People magazine is
citing the Daily Mail for figuring out
who the guy is but it's really important
that everyone knows that the morning
trust Facebook group founded out first
they had his Instagram is linked in his
everything on a thread and I see a
younger man yes so she's 47 he's 29
get it girl his name is Ben Kaczynski
and he is a tech startup investor an
advisor he graduated from the University
of Miami with a degree in Econ in 2011
and he's a managing partner at Kaczynski
Ventures look at houses dad's People
magazine got that from his LinkedIn well
I mean the pictures of him on the tee on
TMZ are like yeah so blurry you can't
see but go look at his instagrams like
Benny Kaczynski and he's hot I looked
him up yesterday I don't get it I mean
just like you know I can't like a
grieving I'm was she wasn't even a
widowed partner dower life partner
important I mean I do see like I
personally wouldn't think I don't think
I can move on quickly or ever me
personally but you know but like you
never know you never know yeah crave
companionship impact have been something
you need to get under someone to get
over someone else right I mean I said my
biggest fear in life is being alone like
I've never lived by myself I hate being
about being alone like at night when Ben
goes I'm his first time this year this
is the first time oh my god I love it
I [ __ ] hate being alone too like I
feel like I would probably like my
slumber parties love thing as long as I
had my own bed though
yeah like I can be all cool and fun like
hang out together like up until we have
to go through any such thing in the same
time when you travel yes yeah but
actually it depends like when I go to
the hotel I said we're open to either a
king bed or a double Queen whatever
gives us the bigger room I've been
called a double Queen many times man
that's gonna change yes for sure yeah
okay well honestly like I
Bethenny she can do no wrong in my eyes
and if getting under a hot man is what
she needs like don't I can't I'm not
gonna knock
I love a romance yeah who loves I love
love yeah and he left her she don't
leave him who the bit dead person left
her he did well he took that he took
those pills and say goodbye oh yeah but
I mean it was accidental and you never
know people struggle with substance to
be just like it's you know it's easier
said than done
mm-hmm what substances are you into
which ones which I'm asking you it what
you like to party what do you like to do
oh I just I drink a time me too alcohol
um Jim probably really yeah I mean vodka
was like cause it's always always there
by George in and I love scotch but
that's like when I'm sitting it's mad I
know a love scotch very smoky smoky
scotch I love that I'm gonna have mixing
Michaels cocktails I love gin martinis I
love gin and tonics I love you [ __ ] with
tequila yeah oh yeah I love margaritas
me too yeah I love them it's Melanie I
don't like it's like probably rum
meeting it sounds gross and like sugary
and that's really I just only crumber
like anything sweet like I don't drink
anything not clear yeah like even the
tequila Reposado that's brown I don't
drink that
yeah I like clear about Glencoe oh yeah
I'm a blonde cokehead again that I love
wine I lovely um I love a citrusy sob
Blanc from New Zealand Marlboro New
Zealand that is what all my sisters yeah
it's it's like you know those twists off
or cork whatever's there yeah yeah I'll
take whatever love a chef han-shan yeah
sorry it's my favorite like mixer I love
Campari
Negroni is my favorite drink which is
gin Campari and sweet vermouth
are you a pearl spritz kind of guy I
don't know I joke Campari spritz because
a girl's too sweet for me yeah I like
comparing just a little bit more bitter
but so I can make the same exact trick I
know our mutual friend Aperol spritz
girl Oh Heather Heather yeah she's your
friend you don't even know her name
I know her what she drinks and knows she
loves Admiral Smith I do the same exact
drink but I do uh Campari got it okay
very interesting I'll smoke it I'll
smoke a weed pen I love I love I love an
edible no I'm not going to shoot
anything up
what about do you ever put like I'm Al
coholic your body do you suppose that
chug I tried to come I sip my niece's to
do it the other day decline
twelve and eighteen twelve and eighteen
but our tampons are soaking tampon ray
vodka oh well I wrote that will air we
actually just funny segments get bit
less a cooking show and I one of the
recipes was had a but chug vodka with
tampons so excited it's not has not been
released yet
okay well look out for that people take
tampons this what the college Cubs are
doing is yeah they soak it in alcohol
and they stick it in our [ __ ] or
girls can do it in their society
yeah but want that burn well yeah but it
goes directly into the bloodstream and
it's so bad for you how much fat should
you get drunk been sticking it in your
mouth it looks like how little time do
you have like if you only that much time
stop drinking well I would think hi hi
so everyone's I'm spraying Geo drain
it's washcloth and huffing it what no it
sprays you and it's called it's called
huffing oh it's like I'm whippets I
guess but they be like spray deodorant
like like right garden so it's so
weirdest thing you know I never
protected party or partake no I'm always
low on deodorant I can't afford to be so
wasteful oh okay this ex Tory is so
crazy and there's a picture that
accompanies it
Joey Kings transformation into convicted
murderer Gypsy Rose Blanchard will give
you the chills so Joey King is
transforming into Gypsy Rose for her
newest role the actress debuted a newly
shaven head on Instagram on Monday to
announce that she will be playing the
murderer in a new Hulu show called the
act Joey told fans my name for the next
four months is Gypsy Rose Blanchard this
story is very disturbing I'm honored to
be able to portray it what a wild ride
this will be on the act so if you see
the picture she has a perfectly round
head and Gypsy Rose Blanchard is a young
woman who brutally killed her own mother
it's a real story yeah DeeDee Blanchard
in 2015 after Dedes body was found in
there she is
yeah in her home the mom's body was
found in their home by a concerned
neighbor the family and friends slowly
began to unravel the truth about what
was going on behind closed doors it was
later discovered that gypsy who everyone
believed to be disabled and very ill
murdered her mother with the help of her
lover Chris go John and Joey King also
video to herself shaving that like
bright name yeah or like did you teen
happily ever after
no oh there's own amazing seats you
showed your own house and all ethan
sheets are had you know you had a person
do it yeah demons head as yes yeah I'm
sure I mean like not like not like
people who have like a full head of hair
like doing it for protest right but I
have like you know of course like you
know girl this hairs gonna go
well I like could never like my hair is
I'm Samson like my hair is my life yeah
I can even security blanket I think if
they offered me like a role in a movie I
still wouldn't do it a film a silver
screen like she looks good oh yeah I
mean that's as good as it's like 16
years old and has perfect bone structure
right like how hard can it be a purple
fun she doesn't need pool spa or doctor
Sharon jeez no okay so no seems easy
easy easy okay not really did to Kanye
okay
distant cousin Kanye Maria Kardashian so
would you add what is the most extreme
thing you would do for a role like would
you gain 50 pounds I I really have yeah
I mean if there's a real Brooks like you
I would do like you know crossing over
from you know the role I have now which
is just a thirst monster into the screen
yeah I think I would do that would you
lose a hundred pounds if they asked you
like you know they mean yeah are they
gonna help me if they're gonna [ __ ]
help me like they'll give me like a
trainer
absolutely absolutely okay and I try to
keep it off yeah no I mean like that
would be a great diet aid like if
someone we'd have a hard time
transitioning into um TV or film no
you're on TV I know but I'm not an actor
or I mean there's a there's an element
of Jersey Shore that is acting yeah it's
not all like real real it's reality it's
fine yeah I guess but you've been on TV
oh yeah we could totally transition I'd
like to start meet you how do we get
there I don't know do we have to go like
to LA for like on pilot season I cannot
get on oh we have stuff here yeah we'd
have to stay here
maybe we can be um I can ask my friend
Nico torella from a television we can be
on younger oh like me and you would just
be like extras what's her name is too
gay best friends or we'd be like her
loud best friend
Lindsay Eliza not Liza Hilary don't we
like Hilary Duff's like college right
college friends and we roll into town
from LA we're so fabulous yeah we're
staying at a penthouse yeah in the Four
Seasons
yeah we'll just walk on and do that yeah
can you set it up yeah I'll call Nico do
you know Taylor's record yes she was
here yesterday no she was he uh she was
here last week but she hosts the younger
after-show
are you there ever no no but she I had
their make me I was just on her show yes
what is your voice your show what does
she have she was on Sirius for a while
and now she does her own morning radio
show and she does something interesting
the younger she does
the younger show and she's just like the
coolest ever she was married for five
years got divorced fell in love with her
best friend also named Taylor and the
two of them were the cutest ever
lovely she's a great story okay Beth
sorry we have such a hard time keeping
on topic with me here I know I'm sorry
I'm just trying to beer back to the
story which yeah this okay so it's crazy
that you shaved your head and I do not
know who Gypsy Rose Blanchard is how
long she is either and just first one is
Joey Ryan is you don't know Joey king is
well she in the kissing booth Netflix
original oh I think I saw it with the
really Oh we watch it together
no but you totally know what I mean oh
did I tell you to watch it no you tell
me to watch any of that hot guy that was
in every [ __ ] movie the Lord no that
was Noah Centennial I told you to watch
to all the boys I loved before
what you should watch you hadn't got a
stab you have a podcast you got to be
got to know these things no but I take a
lot of sleeping pills when I on the
couch and I'm watching Netflix well you
were just tell me about your new diet
where you just take sleeping pills yeah
I take so eat sick of sleeping pills
very early in the morning I mean in the
morning and yeah in the early evening
like around 8:30 p.m. so I can pass out
and I physically can't be binge eating
if I'm sleeping where do you guys know
where do you get the sleeping pills for
my doctor what I need a prescription
yeah I have ambien but I've ambient
unavailable I'll take a xanax okay does
that when available I'll tell you girls
the poor man's a next to go to Costco I
want you to go to Costco and you look
for the knockoff benadryl there are the
hot pink pills and the big thing there's
like it's called an e histamine or
whatever it is they're hot pink you
can't miss them a few of those that's a
poor man's Ana but that's better than
benadryl
it is benadryl it's a so why do you have
to do the off-brand one because they
don't make they don't sell them in a big
jug and the regular ban the regular
better to show them your your ID you
don't make Chrissy laughs yeah I would
know how to do that and they have to pop
them out and then you know if your
readiness in a stupor you can't get that
from the discount store
pour him out and that'll knock you right
out okay good to know knocking right in
the dirt well yeah that's the one that
that's like a night Cove out the
medicine and right it's just like it's
clean I tried them all unisom I was just
like unisom is probably the best one
I've used no crap unless you're a child
a girl is [ __ ] [ __ ]
I recently I used to take melatonin when
I was in high school and like pretend
like it worked I just bought melatonin
cuz I really was having trouble sleeping
yeah and I bought it I felt see but like
11:30 it's a pickup at 5:00 in the
morning
for two hours it's a placebo it's
[ __ ] it's like a fake pill that
should give to like a lab rat be like
okay now yeah this is fake well I just
wanna talk about Gypsy Rose Blanchard
for a minute because I didn't know the
story now that I do and it's crazy
[ __ ] up this show sounds really good
with gypsy so cheap see most Blanchard
murdered her mother and everyone in the
town was trying to figure out who
murdered the mom and Gypsy Rose
Blanchard was pretending to be like sick
and disabled but it turns out her and
her lover killed the mom but it's like
if your name is Gypsy Rose Blanchard
like imagine the life you could have had
like you could have been such a cute
like Coachella Instagram model yeah
instead you had to go and kill your mom
like why who knew not cool
so how'd she kill her mom um it doesn't
say but I got to me for a netbook show
Hulu a Hulu show us a miniseries
miniseries called the act what had she
killer no knows no it doesn't say so she
pretended to be slow so no one would
suspect her hmm but she slowed the whole
time or she Olsen and in nowhere started
becoming like I don't know not with it I
don't know but I guess we'll have to
watch to find out the ax coming - who
lives
was that a semi ad no okay but like it
could have been yeah because that was
like seamless and good I was really good
okay this is something that's we respect
to speak about before it's very personal
to both of us
Cameron Monaghan is exiting shameless uh
so a month after Emmy Rossum announced
that she will be leaving shameless
another star is following suit but he
copied and it's like he look this is
like the last episode he's not gonna
leaving right he's not finishing this
season he's in the middle season and I'm
not caught up on this season because I
watch it all in full because it's not
that good where I don't know how they're
gonna kill him or is he gonna go away -
Cameron Monaghan he's played Ian
Gallagher since shameless debuted in
2011 favorite show
leading the show midway through the
ninth season the 25 year old actor whose
final episode will air Sunday October
14th this Sunday maybe now it's been on
Instagram and Monday that he will one
week after the he announced literally
yes when we get to the season premiere
yes I haven't been watching this new
season because I like to watch it in
faux binge because it's not really that
good of a show yeah when you watch it
all together it's a good and it gets rid
of the day like a day goes by but I've
really been hating the show recently
Sam because I feel like they focus a lot
of the show on Fiona who is just
insufferable and annoying and horrible
it may be the worst decisions and it's
just the worst protagonist yeah fiona
has the same thing like Harry but I hate
yeah Bradshaw I hate her cause she's
like she's a selfish Susan Mayer
desperate housewives yes they're the
protagonists we're supposed to identify
and like them and they are supposed to
ban her make the worst decisions and I
can't watch that yes so Carrie Bradshaw
and Fiona Gallagher have the same
[ __ ] thing where it's like read
you're so annoying just like stupid
stupid
yeah so and then everything just became
so literal like it's like we understand
you I have reference to what's going on
the political climate and the world and
what's going on but that's so [ __ ]
literal like down to like like okay this
one's gonna be trance this one's gonna
be black this one's gonna be a
Republican this one's gonna be gay this
one's gonna be whatever it is it's like
enough already like when he and came out
as gay like in season 2
that was like organic and it was it was
interesting and it was cool to see how
like his family like that when he
started dating that trans kid it was
like okay now they're getting a little
involved viral is gay Jesus and that was
like a little stupid that that's too but
that's the same time that Debbie decided
to become a women's rights activist for
job equality and started [ __ ] route
and wiling out in the in the yard where
they weld [ __ ] and now she's going out
with a transgendered welder well lunch
out with a bunch o methane I'd be like I
think the story with a diaper on pissing
yourself alder was so funny
oh my god except when that thing with
her toe I I almost stopped watching the
show for good that was so disgusting
oh I have a fear of amputees I told that
very last podcast I tell you about this
know terrifying know it like her amputee
in her own toe like it was so disgusting
I'm really like over this show and I
just watch it cuz like when you need
something to watch it's not bad ah I
know it's just like I'm gonna get him
sadly even just like break up with me or
[ __ ] just like state I just want you
through the goers stay good it's like
but like I was I was down when I heard
Emmy Rossum Mosley me I'm like finally
we can see some other character
development
yeah are you pointing at me like I have
something gone I think I'm shiny okay no
your face I was excited and honestly I
need more lip in my life because oh my
gosh hi [ __ ] me in the ass
do you know his girlfriend's pregnant
Addison real life in real life yeah yeah
just every sec seen him and Steve Howey
oh I love him from Carrie Baum yes oh my
babe up I thought Kevin B yeah Kevin B
are my favorite hair I want a Kevin B
spin-off I want a lip spin-off
yes I can just get rid of Debbie
alibi-bar like they haven't Tommy
emphasis at the bar at the alibi yeah I
love all the guys to the alibi and the
Russian yes that was great yeah I like I
I can't it's getting so bad Ben refuses
to watch it where it's like we used to
love it but how is he leaving them it's
like the middle of season so I guess
like if you're following this show I
mean I'm not gonna give I'm not but like
I don't know where he was like go to
prison for life or like memory he was in
the army
know that oh he was the army no yeah
Carl was in the army no Carly Carl one
is at military school but they into West
Point we found that he was colorblind or
he had flat feet and he could just
remember he found out he couldn't go to
the army yeah
also what are you thoughts on Frank I
mean I like Frank I think it's funny ya
know he carries the whole show is him
well then there was drama because
frankly bizarre yeah Willie right will
mhm Macey
who plays Frank in real life and is
married to Lynette from Desperate
Housewives
yes Felicity Huffman he was getting paid
more per episode than Emmy Rossum and
like she went on strike well it's all
about him anyway so while I'm here for
her demanding equal pay up your game
he's a bigger star and a bigger part of
the show and he's more famous and he's
the lead in the show right the show is
less so I thought that was weird but I
I'm not gonna get down on someone for
fighting for their raise you know but
she like I don't think she deserves you
paid as much as well MH Macey he's an
icon you know that Selleck being paid as
much as Donnie Wahlberg on Blue Bloods
that would never happen whatever
happened to that poor girl from the
e-channel that had to quit Catt Sadler
yes
it's very sad because nothing happened
to her like people cared for a minute
and now she's no job you would think
that she's like has her own network
right no she she got injustice like yeah
give me the gavel serve up some justice
for [ __ ] cats out there like that was
not cool she had the same job they were
both just as qualified yes and he was
literally making like four times more as
her and not only Jason what's his name
Jason Kennedy she she didn't leave she
tried to get equal pay and they wouldn't
let her those little [ __ ] and then
she left she deserves justice Emmy
Rossum it's like police you're getting a
million an episode and we'll mhm Macy's
getting like a million and a quarter
yeah please calm down home but so yes
come hermana hands leaving Gino Cameron
Monaghan is dating Peyton list I another
thing I hate about these kind of things
I think
characters ganna show and not in real
life I agree and I don't care it should
be there's enough gay actors enough gay
trans actors that should play the exact
role but it's more about me getting
pissed I have a crush on you I can never
really have sex with you now and that's
also like Matt Bomer who's the hottest
man alive only playing straight man yeah
and he's gay
yes that's annoying I know it's annoying
for both times like just just again we
can't have real sex with you looks like
at least have a fantasy about it can
never ahjumma is true it could
legitimize the fantasy oh what's that
about you're at the doctor your reflexes
well I think this means that shameless
is it's finally like coming to an end
because it's nine seasons it's like
enough ready two people are leaving it's
crumbling I feel like they might
announce that next season as well what
yeah I don't know why you weren't just
like ended between Lin Shu like main
characters leave it says yeah I knew
it's poor timing means not really like a
main character but Emmy is but I'm not
sad with her leading it's 11:11 you
wanna make a wish
yes make one okay you don't say it a lot
if you don't want to Jackie always
wishes her Gucci bag you have one I know
does your dress share clothes and bags
clothes uh-huh no bags yeah okay like I
just bought a bag for her bachelorette
party and I told okand regulations to
Olivia Thank You Shay oh sure she's over
the moon I want to talk about that I
also want to talk about how stunning
that engagement party was that I was
invited to with those balloons in the
background where was that um the
wayfarer in New York yes I'm in sixth
Avenue yeah 57th and 6th I always wanted
to go in there they had a gorgeous room
upstairs
I had my bridal shower there too maybe
somebody had my 40th birthday party this
year the big four oh I think it's a
great day
January 3rd doesn't have to be that day
just any of the week of the three I mean
my friend Eric owns a restaurant so I
think I'll see what I can do where's
this at waiter he owns that I always
pacified superkey it's great across in
the one hotel which is done it's in like
that corporate area so you know he makes
that corporate money coming in for lunch
yeah that's why I like walton that's
very good really a step into like
Williamsburg when you walk in it's very
nice and the food that's what I can do
only two I'm sitting sideways I mean of
course they're gonna be I'm seeing it
who if you had a birthday like who are
the famous people that would be invited
me yo Nicole Nicole
all them yeah would they all come um if
they're in town yeah or not in jail or
not in jail that's everyone
yeah so I have to get might probably
won't make it must be nice to be a
satellite I wouldn't invite Carson
Kressley okay
I invite hello Ross you would that's
Matthew so to go to 10 okay
tea from TLC I'm who else I know just
you know some random just just the elite
gays the elite gay yes Carson I'm very
excited then say like rue RuPaul RuPaul
it's gonna be hosting this was net this
is a side down topic a fixed topic of
the day he's gonna be hosting a new
talent show on CBS
he is getting that corporate money now
and what I'm afraid drag racing that
cable money yes I'm afraid that drag
race is gonna be like down the hill now
he's like hosting what channel is Jaguar
drag race on it's on the h1 h1 okay you
can make good Viacom join me I'm sure
you think about CBS so CBS's that's
gonna be him okay James Corden ooh some
other girl and someone else and they're
gonna be hosting this like Tyga it's
like I'm everything that talent but it's
mostly they might stay worst of all of
them that's what they all say
yeah they all descend up being [ __ ]
singers yeah you know okay well my
birthday party oh yeah
how do I want I wanted to say one more
thing but I don't remember we were
talking about oh I'm glad that RuPaul
like is gets the respect that he
deserves yeah you know what I mean if
like he's like really well respected as
he should be like he wins Emmys yes
snatching Emmys we need an Emmy yeah I
just
and yes I just went to the drag Con in
New York City last year I was on a panel
with Daniel friends they say oh you play
Damien in Mean Girls
yes so sweet and so nice yeah and
sometimes very nice I just met him
magic show yeah you know who else was on
my panel whom Carrie drag Shaw do you
know him yes he does Carrie as dry clean
on his it was all around even like the
little ballerina tutu he was funny I
think it always says like I couldn't
help it wonder yeah he's good it's
really funny okay so this is the final
story
wanted to diversify a little bit and
it's wild and I feel like this is
something you would do if you're gonna
be the relationship anytime soon
Oh God girlfriends bizarre list of
strict rules for her boyfriend goes yes
okay so a bizarre contract that a
girlfriend is written was found in a
traded in car the list of demands
contains 22 things she said her
boyfriend cannot do it includes rules
such as not taking longer than 10
minutes to text her back so this girl so
what this girl like sold her car and she
accidentally left this contract in it
was it signed yes the crime document it
had notes and emojis on it it was a list
of 22 things that her boyfriend had to
sign that he wouldn't do if she were to
enter into a relationship and they both
signed it uh yeah so good you are not to
have a single girl's phone number nope
what about like his mom well she's you
know he should know that by heart and
should not be stored in the phone true
you are not to follow any of them on
social media including Instagram
snapchat and Twitter correct you are not
to hang out with Keegan including his
house or anyone know why Keegan that's
up to battery hose downstairs in base
man you are not to go to Honda without
me but Tom does I don't know and then it
has our handwritten thing next week that
says vroom vroom like Honda dealership
right or like is it a club what's out
there no one knows whereabouts this buzz
you are not hanging out with your
friends more than two times a week I
feel that it's like super annoying Ben
is always with his friend oh no I don't
mind that he's friends like it's
something like get away from me a little
bit but at least I know where he is and
I need to like be able to FaceTime
anytime I need you you are not to look
at a single girl true that if a girl
comes up to you at any place or any time
you are to walk away Moe is to not hang
out every time we hang out no no no is
very clingy it was one of their friends
who you are not to ask for blank it's uh
it's blurred out why did the Daily Mail
blur it out now I need to know what that
one is
you're not to ask for what is it drugs
is it a sexual it was sounds like
something sexual
first cowgirl oh my god how annoying
that they blurted out so leymah well
hawks again let me go to the original
post on twitter yeah if we don't find it
the choices will fill thin I'm sure oh
yeah oh sirs let us know what it says
okay be here there's more you are not to
bring Tyler Noah Devin or even Josh ever
again you are not to get mad at me about
a single thing ever again you are not
allowed to drink unless I am with you
I'm allowed to do a phone check
whenever I please I like that one I'm
the drinking part like let the boy live
this sounds [ __ ] crazy
yeah there's something that you agree
some things I think are nuts okay so if
you had a position together and you had
to have them sign something what would
you have them sign I mean I want to go
that far but I would say break off to me
before if you wanna hook up with someone
else break up with me first
we were on a break do you watch friends
no not a break like like and never see
you again rants yes okay we're chilling
Ross on a break I don't know
I remember how long ago was that oh my
god if you don't know that reference you
don't want trends I watched it
were they broken up or not they were on
a break and he had sex with a girl from
the copy place and she got mad but she
did break up him the night before she
said I want to break well they're not
the night before you can wait a month
and do it well who cares they're on
already
I'm with Ross on this one rich was
[ __ ] annoying okay well I would say
you know just don't no cheating okay duh
I've never been cheated on yes cheated
on anyone never good because you're a
nice boy thank you good at I would never
you want to marry someone to tell you no
you don't care doesn't matter I'm Irina
today I would just say no no social
media and other like apps know like
kinder grinders or ten days I have a
couple of district just for like for
content I've been using chappie okay
which is like the new hip one one of the
toasters found Andy Cohen on chopping it
was nearly screenshot I said that you
Natan I didn't send that you know can I
show you know I saw the red okay yeah I
thought I sent it to I mean I sent it to
you and you did it and he replied back
you said oh my god I hope you swiped
right oh did I she wiped renew to pull
up my social so maybe it wasn't a
toaster but owes you I have dementia I'm
sorry I forgot to mention that that's
right there oh yeah you did while he
looks so cute yeah he doesn't Merrick
you I would swipe right I slept right
he's not I do not know how to type like
everything I text is [ __ ] like ill
ill written so you swept right and you
didn't get Andy Cohen do not but that
means he could also have a three huh
yeah that's like a month to go unless
he's never used this I mean either a
little bit like he needs these apps but
he looks know these pictures but you
know he doesn't very cute I love Andy
and it says that his job is watch repens
live host and executive yeah
that's funny I know so I'm I have that
one I have scruff I don't use that one
as much - that's like for hookups and I
don't men with beards why it's called -
no it's for everyone but it's like
mostly like a scruffy or like roughed up
roughed up at Sacred Heart yes
so this I still want you I have I think
I have um Oh Raya you are you on Raya
Oki Raya is by the way you guys Raya is
it you have to be accepted - it's
supposed to be like for famous people
you know every time I meet someone with
Raya I make them like give me their
phone so I can see if I know anyone yeah
I've never seen anyone cool on it okay
so I was no I wasn't wait let Matthew
Perry I know Matthew Perry's on Raya
okay yes yes Chandler so I was on the
wait list for very long and then I was
with my good friend Nico Chiarello I
have mentioned named ruck twice already
and once before the show so I went to
his phone and I said oh my god email
them here phone and say make my except
my friend but then there's an option
once you remember you're allowed to
invite a friend in so I went he invited
me in so I had like you know I had
someone vouch me that I'm cool I only
want to get on to see who's on and like
network yeah it's at an option yeah I
think it have to be dating you could
choose friend or boyfriend right like
yes so I don't know it really works with
the yep and it's like you should
definitely get on that yeah I think it's
good for me you're Rio worthy yeah I
don't want to like eat some and then
like you know they're not not
comfortable with my lifestyle you know
right what is your lifestyle are you
just getting stopped on the street every
five minutes no it is the fame life it's
not for everyone the paparazzi they have
no sense of privacy
it's okay so we've wrapped on the past
five so I want to dive in okay so I'm
gonna I have a bunch of puts questions
for Joey about Jersey Shore drums and
just like a life stuff in general no but
if you have a question for Joey I've
pulled up the YouTube feed so pop a
question in about anything and I will
get a Tim for our last couple of minutes
I want to talk to about so many things
cuz I think a lot of Jersey drama has
unraveled in the past week and really
excited that I like oh there actually
has been a lot yeah Gio Allen Roger okay
now so they were getting divorced said
she filed for divorce and then Roger
went on Instagram saying he's gonna get
his wife back you know underground blogs
suggest that he cheats on her that does
know I'm fidelity I can say that there's
no one to respect I don't I didn't curse
that no infidelity animal I think what
happened was you know I think it's just
forgetting the day-to-day things getting
one deigned and
I think this kind of thing Oh God you
know thinking Scott they have two kids
and everyone knows her son is going
through a little bit of a drama with his
it's not I'm not sure what's autism or
something he's been therapy okay and
doing so that puts a lot of stress on as
well so it was her decision to file but
I think that are they moving forward
with the filing I don't believe so I
think they're gonna wait and see I
really like how it plays out I love them
yeah I don't love Roger they're so cute
is one of the sweetest people know went
on stole her hard drive and then she
went back to the shore and like fell in
love with Roger like that was my life
yeah he's saved he saved her he did I
mean got to see their whole relationship
unravel and like the most normal way
like they had the most lovely
progression like a real couple they have
ups and downs yeah I think that you know
something that she did but it's like
think I believe they don't they'll work
it out I hope they do me too I love I do
Joe and their kids are so cute and then
there was a major drums with this
situation oh poor thing I know I'd
really like he's become one of my
favorite characters it's like this has
been so humbling he's my favorite
friends he went sweet guy in his White
has a fiance Lawrence is the sweetest
girl they just had their bridal shower
bridal shower yes and then literally the
next day he had a sentencing and we
didn't know was gonna happen he got
sentenced to eight months in prison
correct what kind of prison like legit
or like oh it's for its prison but I
think that it's probably it's not an
it's a maximum security it's a it's a
fence it's a financial right thing it's
a what is it they call it white-collar
crime yeah I think it's what it is I'm
sure to be very like um like Martha
Stewart yes right yeah I mean I think
his saving his saving thing is he's just
a genuinely like happy fun guy funny guy
I mean not in that situation but I think
that when people people can use a little
bit of comedy use a little bit of
livelihood in there
I think people didn't look forward
whoever he gets to meet in prison it's
gonna be grateful because they're really
stuck in there for a long time yeah I
just had that little few months of
someone who has a positive energy who's
turned his whole life around
he's so been sober for two years he you
know was faithful in his how does he do
the show sober like I can't even I don't
know when we're bombs around him he's
just like he's like he takes care of all
of us and make sure we get
I loved him I felt really bad for him I
feel like I know that he did a bad thing
and he should go to jail for years ago
but I feel like he's really like changed
and like he learned his lesson like I
feel like he wouldn't ever do it again
no and the rehabilitation that he's
gonna get in prison he doesn't need he's
already done it himself and I'm really
sad about it like I really feel for him
I'm so upset
his haman Lauren's wedding is coming up
and I'll be attentive they're gonna get
married before you go to prison yes
they're getting married when I can't do
the date the next where in the next few
couple months before he goes where New
Jersey okay
they'll be getting married in North
Jersey I could say that is everyone
invited yes of the cat's in the wedding
Angelina invited are there to see end
and milani Nicole and Jenni's kids our
bridal flower girls okay are the boys
groomsmen
yes that's so cute yeah I love that yeah
I think no wait yes I believe so there's
gonna get for the show so you'll see it
all oh good good he's making that money
cuz yeah he's gonna leave his wife all
alone well he needs that that MTV
Lawrence yes so she'll be uh but I think
it'll be hopefully I'm praying that it
goes quicker then why do you keep all
your Lawrence that's what he calls her
okay okay her name is Lauren Lauren yeah
what we call her she's so cute we call
our Lawrence she's beautiful Peter so
pretty and really like his anchor yes
I'm grounded
exactly exactly high school sweetheart
yeah so I'll be wearing um it's black
tie and I'll be wearing a tuxedo from
the black tux okay
it's a pillock order it's like Rent the
Runway that protective oh yeah it's
called the black tux tell her I'm been
about it if I owned the tux yeah
just arrested saloon what's that those
fancy slippers those like smoking
slippers that like show parts of your
feet a little bit yeah but they're
Louboutin oh that's right I saw this
yeah he isn't so she sent me he's so
obnoxious
um okay more questions for you so you
were on a recent episode of Jersey or
how many episodes I I watched the first
season when they came back to Miami
because I heard the novelty of it and
like I was so invested and actually at
the same time I was rewatching the
original first six seasons I was like up
to Florence already oh because that was
like my life like I was so yes the
original Jersey Shore like while it was
happening so I'm not keeping up with
what's going on now they're in Vegas no
they left Vegas now there are going back
to the shore
the episode that you were on a brew in
Vegas yeah and what you do uh we got I
got bombed took hold Jenny like left
because she had to go deal with stuff at
home and Vinny left because he had to go
his uncle died so it was really just
everything I had to go hanger I didn't
have to go I was so you know I came
because everyone was leaving so I went
over there and it was me Angelina Mike
Pauly and Ron and Nicole and jenni was
there the first night and then we've got
wild so I went we went to the club Pauly
was like DJing at we got bombs there
I poured ice buckets over my head when
you go to the club filming you don't
have to pay for anything right now who
picks it up or is it free I don't know
it's MTV I guess does it give me the
role of a burr like escort it in and we
get like we get to the middle area of
like the club usually they have like a
big section roped off for us already and
we just get in there and then they just
start like you know they start like you
know pouring pouring drinks and then
start inviting people and I think they
know producers are like send people in
to see like how we react to them and
stuff and like it would become friends
with me they would become friends you
need anyone sex with them I hooked up
with a guy at a pool party for you yes
so it was a camera yeah we just made out
in like a Cabana but like me and
Angelina are swimming and like we saw
like two boys and like I just like
started talking to them and they had one
happened to be gay and then one thing
led to another and we started making out
in the booth not the booth the cabana
good for you I went on that surfboard
thing uh-huh
that is very dangerous it's very
dangerous and I instead of wiping out my
pores
yes came down whoa cool my whole ass and
dick was out and I was flopping around
like a dead whale in the water it was
not my best showing but okay but you got
to be on TV so that's all that matters
yeah so when you go on no put the paper
flight yes of course yeah your class yes
nice yeah read yeah very rich so no they
are there every was great to me so we
did the new season there would be more
episodes we filmed that have not aired
yet okay at the shore where are they
filmed this one yeah which one that's
true at the shore we did and the wedding
to be filmed in they just here and there
so I'll be making a few more appearances
here and there that is very exciting
yeah it's uh it's fun yeah they're like
they're like great friends who've been
friends for so many years almost seven
years now so it's like it's just like
hanging out with your friends getting
bombed so I say that the DNA's where you
had better taste in me because you were
with smoking and you know and the whole
cast and I want to ask you a question
because you were seated with Nicole and
JWoww yes and then the rest of the cast
was seated one row behind you
why we're Nicole and JWoww giving better
seats than everyone else I think because
they have more cred on MTV they've had
their own spin on their own show but in
the firehouse nicole has now three shows
with MTV sisters he sure is the tattoo
show and then she has a secret show of
leading her on that we can't talk about
yeah that's her a nice show what mm-hmm
can I come on as a guest it's already
filmed it but with next season thank you
you were like the most difficult person
to nail down for a co-host I feel like
I've asked you three times right she
asked well you asked me good night
before one time one time the second time
was like the second day before oh please
[ __ ] you asked me yesterday well no we
go here I'm at three o'clock if I could
come at 4:45 to film okay then shut up
yeah
hey Simon I want to know about your
schedule yeah like you travel with
Nicole everywhere yeah yeah pretty much
so I do I mean we do have more like you
know could do her hair and her makeup
all right also we just like we're best
friends so we go everywhere together so
I mean we don't travel the globe I mean
we're not going wild places but you know
usually they could know anywhere we have
to travel there usually involving it for
press or for an appearance or something
so that's why where I come in so you
know to jazz her up and then we also
have like you know having your best
friend like when you in snitch go it's
like having your best friend with you
it's the best yeah so it rocks yeah
very very good care good and you love
the kids right oh they're so sweet
Johnny like Johnny they loved you I
loved Jenny so I hit on I see him years
ago I'm happy that they found someone
like for each other like that is so
height appropriate yeah he thinks we are
so ridiculous sure he liked roses eyes
at us and he like makes fun of us and
calls us messes and all the time he he's
a perfect father the perfect husband
he's like so I said he liked it he's
definitely like looks at me in a coma
roses eyes
24/7 saying you guys are nuts no he did
he did the surgery sure no but he they
had a spinoff nice to know there's a
show where they were flipping houses oh
it was on FYI network who did cookie
cookie and her husband huh and they have
a flipping house show and he's so into
that so he loves that parks is all about
him and his work and things he loves not
about personal life not about drama not
about drinking and getting messed up or
personal relation
really just about him doing the brain
loves he does house flipping he
renovates houses he buys and sells and
he does all that stuff so he was really
happy in that element of it but he's not
he's a very shy guy he's doesn't like
being out in the public he doesn't like
being sharing his life and he's sweating
nicole's it's a coal stop and not his
and he like lets her do her thing and he
doesn't want to be on camera he's really
thirsty monster that's that's why that's
why I'm there well people want to know
if you've ever met Jay Viet and Jonathan
Van Ness no but I can't stand him what
why I can't I mean I can't stand I just
think when I watch it it's too much like
I'm too much that he takes it on
overdrive and I think when he was like
on that show I wanted to UM the first E
in the show there's like a time to place
to wile out and like be extra extra gay
and the I just it was so uncomfortable
he's like forcing this craziness on he's
like I'm like I'm suspecting like
straight men in the middle of nowhere
and he's like oh my girl at work and
he's like freaking out ring is so
uncomfortable
for the people deal with him that and
then I think everyone thinks he's so
funny and like that's what I'm also
annoyed by because I am jealous that he
has and I tried out for that show and I
didn't get it out for that show I showed
up for that position for the hair meet
for the beauty position and I I do not
get a call back
of course you hate him yes of course
they hate him it's like you know it's
he's being successful there he's
snatching Emmys and it's like that could
have been made million powers yeah I
know you've been so great at it actually
I know someone else who tried out for
that same role yeah it's a hard who okay
but it's you know it's uh but otherwise
I know by people like him I just can't
stand him cuz he has everything I want
ya know but people always say like your
show is so mean you say such mean things
about people you're just jealous and
like obviously her all the jig is up
yeah did you guys have like people I
can't believe you so mean about Meghan
Marcos letting on Michael
Meghan Marco is literally a princess and
I'm literally like eating Chinese food
in my bed of course I'm jealous
yeah be in tune one more question for
you before I'll let you go okay some
people wanted to know about something
that have one Jonathan Cheban
no drama there's enough drama Jonathan
Cheban the food god he came on our
podcast I invited him on the podcast I
met him out with my friend melissa gorga
yes so we were all at
one night having dinner and and Jonathan
was there so we all sort of hang out
there and then we became we became
friendly and then I invited wants to the
podcast so he came on the podcast and
everyone said the episode is still there
if you go to UM it's happening look for
the one that with the food guy and
everyone said he was so horribly mean
and condescending and such a jerk off
and so nasty to me Oh to you to me and
so everyone's saying what a jerk when
asked how horribly was to me I take it
as the waist a willing to call like all
my friends treat me it's like you know
I'm like not the butt of the joke but
it's like you know I'm like asking
questions like like oh what about this
he's like um I can't believe I've never
flown coach or they've never done this
like acting like that's his that's his
brand is like an uber
you know show off right and I'm like a
goober naive person like oh my god you
don't have to pay for that so it was
like kind of that dynamic and he got a
bad rap for it there's no bad blood we
text all the time he well now that makes
sense because I've been trying to get
him on this show yeah
and he says I won't do a podcast anymore
I'm like why he's like I did one and I
got such bad feedback from it and like
it was mine yeah okay well bat make
sense that he won't [ __ ] come on I'm
like trying to get him on but like
really come on the toast then he won't
come on the toast he said I did one and
I was cured I will never do it again he
said it's not for me I'm she's very like
people don't ever go to roasted him so
horribly right I had so much fun
where were being good friends and we get
out to dinners and stuff he gets her
buddy on his YouTube channel he's doing
a food food food channel check that one
out follow him there I feel like he gets
a bad rap because everything he people
see him in is like about someone else
like he's on the Kardashians and he's
like talking to Kim about Kim and Kim's
life and Kim's things because he gets
paid to do that like that to us
so I feel like people don't actually
know that he himself is hysterical like
I he's so funny he's so funny like I've
had the first time I ever went out to
dinner with him I was shocked by how
funny was and then I just started to
really like him as a person and people
like mighty hanging out with him on
Mikey's livery so funny he's only been
nothing but nice to me sing and I liked
him and I wanted to come on the show
because I want people to see like he can
hang he's so funny in he is such good
gossip and he's just weirdly in very
cool places a lot and sees a lot of
things yeah but he won't come on cuz she
ruined it so thank you I'm sorry but he
does good attention he's very sweet and
polite yes I like him I uh people was a
classy [ __ ] for it and I will defend him
because he's been a good friend to me so
whatever
thank you Joey Joey where can people
keep up with you and your
never-ending thirst monstering you can
do follow me on instagram i'm verified
there i had to pay for it how much
number kid I got a pay Nicole got it for
me for free for my birthday nice no so
it's Instagram at mr. P 79 that spilled
out Mis Terp at 79 and then on my
YouTube on my youtube name it start
youtubing its and showing joey camasta
perfect i can follow me on 88th Street
where I live up to my apartment too deep
[ __ ] it
thank you so much thank you guys we're
back tomorrow Jackie will be back she's
on her way home from Dallas as we speak
so we'll be back just just the two of us
Wednesday and Thursday Friday we'll see
what's happening because I'm in Atlanta
for my show so make sure to get tickets
at Carl's no job com thank you all so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook and YouTube and we're
also available anywhere podcasts can be
listened to so make sure to subscribe in
iTunes or Spotify we'll see you tomorrow
bye toasters